- So what did your
friends and family think?
'Cause it's literally one
of my, I think my sisters,
that's one of the favorite
things I've ever done.
- I mean, my mom sent me the clip,
I think between four and seven times
as if I wasn't there doing it
and then hadn't seen the first three.
So yeah, she was all systems go
sending it out to friends and family.
I think Dan Levy
was basically hospitalized
when he found out that I
was gonna be on your show
and really only started
talking to me again
because he was just so jealous
that I got to perform with you.
But he was also jealous
that I was the first one
from the show that got to be on your show.
Oh my gosh, and we love.
I mean, does the whole
"Schitt's Creek" cast,
do y'all just think I'm nuts.
'Cause I totally got up
there and I was like,
"I think this should be "Schitt's Creek"
and it wasn't a dis to anyone else.
I just love y'all's chemistry, your vibe.
The show is so great.
Do y'all think I'm nuts?
You probably think I'm nuts,
like Meryl Streep.
- No, no.
We all have experienced
that full flustered,
we all whispered about
you after you came up
and said hi to us.
It was really a big deal.
- Oh man, I'm just such a fan.